WE'LL WATCH WHERE THE STORY
GOES.
THANKS IN D.C.
>> Dana: FOR MORE LET'S BRING IN
AN EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR FROM THE
AMERICAN INSTITUTE.
I'M RARELY SHOCKED BY THIS.
WHAT GILLIAN JUST REPORTED SEEMS
TO ME TO BE SO BEYOND THE PALE.
LET'S GET YOUR TAKE ON IT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
LOOK, WHEN THEY RECRUIT A
VOLUNTEER FORCE BRANDON JUDD IS
RIGHT, THERE IS A CRISIS ALONG
THAT BORDER.
IT INFURIATES ME.
THEY AREN'T TRYING TO SOLVE THE
PROBLEM BUT MANAGE THE INFLUX OF
INDIVIDUALS COMING ACROSS THAT
BORDER AND THAT'S FINE.
WE HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF THEM AND
YOU HAVE TO PROCESS THEM.
WHERE ARE THE MEASURES THAT
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE THIS SO IN
2 OR 3 AND 6 MONTHS FROM NOW WE
AREN'T IN THE SAME PLACE.
THAT'S WHERE THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS FALLING ASLEEP.
THEY HAVE NO PLAN IN PLACE TO
TRY TO REDUCE THE NUMBERS, TO
DRAW THIS CRISIS TO A CLOSE.
INSTEAD THEY CONTINUE TO MANAGE
THIS THROWING MORE PERSONNEL
WHETHER IT'S A VOLUNTEER FORCE
OR MORE BORDER PATROL AGENTS TO
PROCESS THE MIGRANTS IN EVERY
SINGLE DAY IN NUMBERS HISTORICAL
NUMBERS WE'VE NEVER SEEN BEFORE.
THAT'S WHAT IS FRUSTRATING TO
ME.
I KNOW THERE ARE THINGS THAT
WORK.
I KNOW THERE ARE WAYS TO
MITIGATE THIS CRISIS.
THIS ADMINISTRATION DOES NOT
SEEM INTERESTED IN DOING ANY OF
THAT.
>> Bill: WOW.
THEY WANT PEOPLE TO VOLUNTEER TO
PICK UP GARBAGE ALONG THE
BORDER.
I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU DEFINE THAT
JOB OR WHERE THAT CAME FROM.
SEE WHETHER OR NOT THEY CAN
RECRUIT THE WAY THEY WANT TO.
MAYORKAS WAS SPEAKING OVER THE
WEEKEND.
REMEMBER WHEN KAMALA HARRIS
SAYING THE BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
THE WHOLE IDEA ABOUT THE BORDER
IS OPEN, TWO YEARS?
WE GO TO BILL MELUGIN EVERY DAY.
EITHER A DRONE IN THE SKY,
CAMERA ON THE GROUND, AND I MEAN
FOR YOURSELF IF YOU THINK THE
BORDER IS NOT OPEN.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THIS COMMENT BY THE SECRETARY IS
BEYOND THE PALE.
BASICALLY WHAT HE IS SAYING IS
ALL THE AMERICANS OUT THERE OUR
POLICY LEADERS AND MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS CONCERNED ABOUT THE
ISSUE AND SPEAKING OUT ON IT ARE
SOMEHOW TO BLAME FOR THE CRISIS,
THAT THE SMUGGLERS ARE ONLY
LISTENING TO THESE FOLKS AND TO
NEWS MEDIA, FOX NEWS AND OTHERS
SAYING THAT THE BORDER IS OPEN.
THAT'S ABSURD, RIGHT?
THEY KNOW IT'S OPEN BECAUSE OF
THE POLL SEALS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY KNOW IT'S OPEN BECAUSE
EVERY MONTH THEY GET HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF INDIVIDUALS TO
CROSS THAT BORDER.
EVERY MONTH THERE IS MORE AND
MORE GOTAWAYS.
THE SMUGGLERS DON'T NEED TO
LISTEN TO POLITICAL FOLKS OR
ANYONE ELSE TALK ABOUT THE
BORDER IS OPEN.
THE REALITY IS THE BORDER IS
OPEN, THEY KNOW IT IS OPEN AND
CBP INTERVIEWS FOLKS EVERY DAY,
MIGRANTS EVERY SINGLE DAY.
THE MIGRANTS ARE SAYING THE
BORDER IS OPEN AND WHY WE'RE
COMING HERE.
SO THIS IDEA AND THIS COMMENT
FROM THE SECRETARY IS TRYING TO
SHIFT BLAME.
THE BLAME, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY
IS ON THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION.